-While I have you here,
can I beg you, can you
do your Bjork impression?
-Sure.
[ Laughs ]
-'Cause you --
It made me laugh so hard.
What, you were in a singing --
-I was a performer
at Hersheypark.
-Yeah, and then
you would come out as Bjork.
And just
no one asked you to do it.
-No one asked me to do it.
It was so that I didn't
absolutely go insane and bur
the theater to the ground.
You have to do like six shows --
six days a week,
five shows a day.
-What would it sound like again?
-I had to sing, like,
a country song with it,
and I'd be like...
[ As Bjork ]
♪♪ I've been cheat ♪♪
♪♪ Just been mistreated ♪♪
And I would do, like,
the whole thing.
And it never went well.
-It is one of the best
impressions of Bjork
I've ever heard, I love it
-We also had to sing "Respect,
like, R-E-S-P-E-C-T.
The judge -- The woman who
played the judge had to sing it,
and so I had do background like,
"Ooh, ooh,"
but I would also try that
as Bjork, so I'd be like..
♪♪ Err, ewr ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-"Err, err."
I was like...
♪♪ Ewr, ewr ♪♪
Yeah. It was --
It was not welcomed,
let me tell you.
-Didn't you say --
Didn't someone stand up an
actually boo you or something?
-Yeah, they stood up
and actively booed me
at the end when I came out
This guy that would come
to every show.
-I love that.
-Every single show.
He saw all of them.
We did 7,000.
And he sat in the front ro
and, like, would sing along.
And then, that day,
he was like..."Boo!"
-"I've had enough!"
-It came, like, the --
-Deep, like -- exactly.
From, like, his toes, yeah
-Can you do
any other impressions?
If I name --
-Yeah, let's try it.
-Uh, Cher.
-"Oh, hello.
My name is Cher."
[ Light laughter ]
-That almost sounds like Bjork
-No, no, no, no.
-No, no, no, no, no.
Hold on.
How about, uh, Drew Barrymore?
-"Oh, my name is Drew Barrymore,
and I have a talk show."
[ Laughter ]
Sounds just like her.
-I'll just throw
anything out there.
-Yeah, come on.
-Rihanna.
-"My name is Rihanna.
And three is a Rihanna Navy.
[ Laughter ]
"When is the album
going to drop?"
-Booooo!
[ Laughter ]
-Wait! You're getting a bo
from the guy that comes every --
-This feels familiar!
This is like déjàà vu!
-You're feeling it now?
-Yeah.
Let's just --
-All you need is, like,
a giant bucket hat.
-That is what he had?
-Yeah.
-Gosh.
-Oh, he didn't come
to make friends,
he came to watch.
He came to take it in.
-Wow. Every single day.
-Every single day.
Oh, yeah.
-Well, look at you now, man.
Hey, buddy, boo this!
Boo this, bud!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
Uh, we love you.
We love you, pal.
Thank you so much
for coming back to our show...
-Thanks for having me.
-...and doing everything.
Cristin Milioti, everybody
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]